foreign
let's go to Tommy in Pittsburgh PA what
up Tommy
how's it going Dr John rocking on to the
break of dawn my man what are you doing
I am in the Florida Keys on vacation so
good times well thanks for kicking us
while we're down hope that was fun for
you I hope that was fun for you we're
all at work Tommy real cool man real
cool what's up
so uh I'll just get into my question
here uh a huge fan I've bought your book
um listen to all your stuff and it's
it's really helped me grow and and find
a lot of Peace but uh the question is um
the more your material and just
psychology material in general I read it
seems like everything of that makes up
who we are comes from our upbringing and
our environment and experiences nothing
we do is really buy our hand
um and looking around I feel guilty for
how good I've always had it um I'm so
high on life when it seems like so many
people are so low and this can also
manifest itself in feeling like feeling
incredibly responsible for some of the
relationships in my life
um
man there's a lot here can I unpack
almost all of it is that cool
yeah
um
first thing is you're partially correct
and
so much of who we are comes from the
stories we were born into and the
stories we were told
and
um I always make a a a very intentional
point to point out that also who we are
is made up of the things we've done our
experiences the way we see the world the
the people we've hurt the people we've
taken care of and so it's a mix of both
okay so just to free you from any
nonsensical guilt you may feel
every single person
ever
who's made it to whatever that means
that means they got their first job as a
plumber or that means they're a
multi-billionaire
they have had somebody or people in
their corner there is no such thing as a
self-made man or woman I reject that
notion it doesn't exist it's a myth okay
so
um everyone had a like a coach or a
business partner or a romantic partner
had some grandparent teacher whoever
walking alongside him or a group of
people or someone who gave them their
first opportunity or somebody who said I
believe in you whatever that thing is
and even if you didn't have a
quote-unquote person you want to fight
me on that then I'll tell you that you
went to your first job on roads paved by
other people and use electricity on
lines pulled by other people and you
dial into your laptop on a computer made
by other people and we can just go down
the list here and so the idea that
you're sitting there Tommy and you're
like man
all these other people have just been
doing it on their own and grinding it
out and I've had this awesome life where
other people help me out that's not true
okay none of us got to where we are by
ourselves period
end
you've had more of a head start right
tell me how you've had a head start
uh I mean
uh parents that always took care of me
they never
got divorced or fought
um anytime I went through trials and
tribulations they supported me
financially emotionally they taught me
how to connect with people so I can have
friendships I've always been good at
sports and connecting with people can
kind of
pick up any talent that is thrown my way
and then I just feel like I've always
just been
able to like also just let things go and
enjoy the things that I'm into
um and uh like I said even I've
definitely faced tribulation just like
anybody else
um but
it's just kind of like how far do you go
back like even when I face difficulties
um I've had people that have shown me
how to overcome those kind of things how
to look at the good how to choose
gratitude and so it's kind of like
everything that's good in my life I feel
like
I owe to kind of how I was growing up
and
uh even the things that haven't been
good I learned from someone how to
overcome those and find relationships
and make them good so it's just kind of
like like I said feeling guilty of like
everything I owe to someone else
something I yeah all of us are in that
boat
and what I'll tell you is your parents
have given you the world
and one day you're gonna get hit in the
mouth in a profound way somebody you
love is gonna die 100 chance that
happens
um you're gonna get fired you're gonna
fail you're going to violate one of your
core moral values in a moment of
weakness
those things will happen because that's
the Ark of life
and so while they may have set you up
over here
they may have taken some of that burden
from you and it's going to hit you
harder because it's going to happen in
your 30s when you've got a mortgage and
two kids and what I'm saying and the
other side of it is
my friends that only had a single parent
and they were working three jobs and
they were left alone and one of their
brothers is in jail and the other sister
they haven't really talked too much
anymore and they decided I'm going to
figure out a way to get through school
and I'm going to grind and I'm going to
do they've got that side they know how
to get hit in the head and they had to
get hit in the mouth what they don't
have is a path for how do I communicate
to this group of people and how do I so
everybody's got stuff to learn
what I'll tell you is your guilt
helps nothing
okay and so
you've got a couple of paths forward
here but I want you to start shifting
really hard man from guilt to gratitude
wake up every day and don't be like oh
man I don't have any Mike my parents
never fought thank God your parents
didn't do that be super grateful that
your parents are still married okay what
you're gonna have to do like so let me
give you an example for me
um
I was uh real real fast in high school
as a runner very very fast
and like full scholarship to college
fast and I was one of the weakest
members of my Texas high school football
team
and so I always have to put in the work
where I know I'm gonna have shortcomings
and so for you as you look around your
life and you say okay I got I got shot
out of the cannon ahead of
people in my class head of people that
aren't in the school that I'm at I got a
head start on this on this track great
what are you gonna do with that Head
Start you just deciding to walk helps
nobody
you deciding to help the people running
around you now you're talking about
changing your community changing your
life changing everybody's life and so
the question is not how can I tear up
this lottery ticket I got and throw in
the trash it's how can I use this for
maximum good for me my community my
neighborhood my country my family and
everybody in between does that make
sense
so
I want you to start choosing the hard
path what does that look like that may
mean your parents take care of all your
bills you don't have to work go get a
job
that may mean that your parents uh bail
you out every time you get in trouble
the next time say I'm not taking your
money this time I need to learn how to
deal with this thing
that may mean that you regularly
surround yourself with people who have
life harder than you
and practice Service practice empathy
practice listening
so that you get an understanding of not
just a conceptual understanding but a
real hard-nosed understanding that the
world is not
um for most people how you experience it
and then you become you you start
learning ways okay I can I can be of
support and service here you see what
I'm saying
yeah I'd say like the second part of
that is
I feel like the reason I've
like I I feel like part of the reason I
feel guilty is like I've had that life
punched in the mouth moment like uh you
know like suicide watch like life sucks
for like a month or you know a few
months and like
now it's like like I definitely like
live with Incredible empathy and
gratitude and so it's more so like
just not yeah bro but you're staring at
your belly button
yeah
you're great grateful and empathetic
towards yourself
and that just that just runs you around
in a circle man
you got to look up and see the world
around you and get involved in in other
people's lives as they invite you don't
come into some sort of Savior as they
invite you
okay so that's that's the second piece
is like
the incredible responsibility like I
have had friendships and relationships
where
I can see where someone's hurt comes
from or like what they're struggling
with and it's like I don't know
sometimes I'm like like
am I carrying too much of this
and I need to like
like I feel like I'm if I leave them
it's like just another person that
disappointed them like I can feel that
pain or like I put that on myself
yeah I mean you've you've got no
business in somebody else's pain unless
they invite you in
okay does that make sense like I do this
for a living and it's really hard for me
sometimes to be sitting next to someone
I love and or someone I care about or a
stranger that I just met and they're
telling me what's going on in their life
and they're not asking for my input or
my support or my help or anything
they're just they're just vomiting on me
and uh I have to make a choice to I want
to continue to get vomited on
or do I want to step back and say thank
you so much I appreciate your honesty
and you see what I'm saying like I can't
just jump in the middle of everybody's
issues because then I'm using them to
prop Me Up
and if you feel guilty about how the the
set of cards you were dealt
and you're going around trying to solve
everyone's problems around you
as some sort of ways to make amends for
all this Good Fortune you've had
dude and then you're using people around
you very similar to someone who's
struggling with addiction who asks all
their friends for money all the time
you're trying to take something from
them to make you feel okay
and what that tells me at the core is
you don't feel okay with you
and it could be from guilt I'm actually
not buying the your full story if I'm
just being honest with you I think
you're super talented I think you've got
great family support and I think you
probably struggle mightily with
depression it'd be my guess am I right
I would say it's
like 95 percent of the time I'm really
high and then
the others would be the opposite okay
and then you feel guilty for feeling bad
don't you I feel guilty when I'm high
do you do you talk to somebody a
professional
I have
why'd you stop
uh
so I felt like so at that time I was
like really low didn't value myself
uh worked through a lot with like family
and friends and then went complete
opposite felt the best I've ever felt
and I feel like I've been there ever
since I've like feeling good about who I
am
okay but now I feel like I left all
you're talking about is feelings what
are you doing
what do you mean exactly you are being
dragged around by a leash
and the the person on the other end of
the leash is your feelings
I felt really bad and then I felt really
good and now I feel great and now I feel
that what are you doing
are you in school
no I'm uh I just I finished my masters
like six months ago and I'm a Fisheries
biologist okay are you working
yeah full-time how's that going are you
contributing
yeah do you have good purpose I feel
like I feel like I create
uh like I'm basically I get to work with
improving Fisheries so that people get
to enjoy them with their friends and
family okay
um
here's what I want you to do I want you
to step back and begin to look at what
this purpose look like for you man
because it sounds a lot
I don't know man quite honestly I think
you and I need to spend some more time
together
um which means I think you should sit
down with a counselor and say okay I've
had these moments where it was really
low I had these moments where I was
super high and now I'm kind of leveling
out into this is the rest of my life I
got my graduate degree I got my job
um and I've got a lot of good fortune
that I'm resting upon
what am I going to do in the next stage
of my life to be a contributor and not a
taker
what am I how am I going to be a maker
how am I going to be a like someone who
encourages others helps others supports
others and at the same time doesn't use
others for my savior complex what am I
going to do there
and begin a relationship with a
counselor not because you're in crisis
anymore but because you are looking at
head heading off into what comes next
for you in the world you want to build
for yourself you can't keep riding on
Mom and Dad anymore and they shot you
out of the canon in in a profound way
awesome
and hear me say this again walking
around feeling guilty for your good
fortune does not help anybody
at all
looking around taking your eyes out of
your own belly button and looking around
at the world around you and saying how
can I be of service and care for these
folks how do I use this ticket for good
that's that's that's the greatest gift
you can give humanity and yourself by
the way
and maybe therapy is not for you great
get a group of guys and y'all meet every
Monday night every Wednesday night every
Thursday whatever pick one night a week
you'll always get together you'll always
hang out and you be honest with them you
tell them the truth you invite them into
your life and maybe if you're lucky two
or three of them or one or two of them
will invite you into their life
and now you've got the making of a
long-term friendship long-term
relationship so we can go from there
but I want you to pick your head up and
not just figure out think about your
academics and your life and yours
start looking around
you got a gift man you got a gift
tearing up that gift and throw it in the
trash doesn't help nobody feeling guilty
about that gift doesn't help anybody
looking for where can I use this gift to
be of the most value to the most people
around me now we're talking